الى لبنان حيث اصدر النائب العام في بيروت
قرارا بمنع حاكم مصر في لبنان المركزي
رياض سلامه من السفر ومصادره جوازي سفرها
اللبناني والفرنسي وتركي رهن التحقيق
والتي قرار القضاء بعد الاستماع الى اقوال
سلامي على خلفيه مذكره التوقيف الدوليه
التي اصدرها الانتربول بحقه بناء على طلب
من القضاء الفرنسي
الجديد نتابعه مع مراسل الجزيره ايهاب
العقدي من امام قصر العدل في بيروت تفضل
ايهاب
نعم حاكم المصرف المركزي جرى استجوابه
بشان حيثيات صدور قرار الانتربول الدولي
بتوقيفه بناء على المذكره التي اصدرها
القضاء الفرنسي لذلك اعتبر القضاء
اللبناني بان الاجراء يجب ان يكون
بمنعه من السفر وبالتالي مصادره جوزي سفري
اللبناني الدبلوماسي وايضا الفرنسي وهذا
اجراء عادي لبعض القضايا التي تجري في
لبنان خصوصا في قضايا مثل اختلاس الاموال
وتبييضها كما يجري في قضيه حاكم المصرف
المركزي وبالتالي فان حاكم المصرف المركزي
يمكنه ممارسه عمله بطريقه عاديه لكنه ابقي
رهن التحقيق اي انه بقي رهن اشاره القضاء
للاستماع الى اقواله في حال حاجته اليها
في حال حاجته اليه لتقديم بعض الاضاحات
الاخرى حول
نحو المذكره التي كانت رافعتها فرنسا الى
الانتربول الدولي علمنا ايضا ان حاكم
المصرف المركزي ابدى رغبته
بالمحاكمه او متابعه قضيته في لبنان وليس
في الخارج لكن عمليا فرنسا الان تحقق في
ملف تزوير واختلاف اموال لسلامي ولعدد من
مساعديه وايضا اللوكسمبورج والمانيا وهي
تنسق فيما بينها
جرم يشتبه بان سلامي قام به بتزوير وايضا
اختلاس اموال وتبييضها في عدد من الدول
الاوروبيه سلامي ايضا
جرى الادعاء اليه امام القضاء اللبناني
لكنها لم يجد لم يجري توقيفه باي من التهم
المنسوبه اليه لازال سلامي يعتبر نفسه
بانه بريء وقدم دفوعا امام القضاء
اللبناني وهو ايضا قدم وجهه نظره
للجنه محققين من اوروبا كانت زارت لبنان
خلال الاشهر الماضيه عده مرات وقال لهؤلاء
بان كل التهامي المنسوبه اليه هي تهم
باطله ولا يوجد لدى ادله يمكن ان تدينه في
اي من الملفات او من القضايا الموجهه ضده
من امام قصر العدل في بيروت مراسل الجزيره
ايهاب العقد شكرا جزيلا لك